Musou
Activation Transformation Musou Dragon Sword Technique Shining Arrow Spiral Ra Hengen Musou
Tsutsu I see, it looks like I'll be a bit of an opponent.
Rishia-san, you should try to understand me as soon as possible. No,
I won't accept what's happening now.
Even if you are robbed of it, it's the one who is the Hen Musou Ryuougi 1. There is no way that
my justice of Ryu [Music] can be stopped by the level of Lisia-san. I
want it. Don't worry about it.
Fanatic self-boost skill. I'll be
swamped by that power.  Don't let it go quickly, you stinky person who
foolishly believes in his own justice and
pushes forward If I were to put it in terms of 7 major powers, let's call it arrogance.
If you use the power of Curse any more, you won't be able to get away with it. There's no
mouth to speak of evil,
Shadow,
bind, bind.
Arrow, I won't give in yet, no, this is the end. The
name of that foolish metal punishment is the
roasting of a mid-neutral bull. Like a cow that wants to be roasted, it
lets out a death scream and torments the Phalaris
Blue
Sea.